i
[Música]
ah
la nominación formal este miércoles de
la candidata demócrata a la
vicepresidencia kamala harris cambia
completamente el panorama electoral de
este país no solamente porque con esta
elección las mujeres afroamericanas se
escriben un nuevo capítulo en la
historia de eeuu sino también por el
impacto que tendrá en millones de
mujeres en este país por un lado que en
las mujeres afroamericanas cuyo voto
precisamente es muy importante en
estados clave como michigan florida
carolina del norte o pensilvania mujeres
que ven en ella una persona con fuerza y
poder suficiente para que las cosas
cambien impactará también
considerablemente en las mujeres latinas
que se ven en ella como en un espejo una
mujer que ha conseguido ser candidata a
la vicepresidencia de este país la
tercera ya lo fue en el 2008 sarah palin
o en el 1984
geraldine ferraro todo en un momento en
el que precisamente se cumplen 100 años
de que las mujeres pueden votar en este
país desde luego todo una premonición
[Música]
desde 1932 a las mujeres pueden votar en
unas elecciones en el puerto rico y
desde hace más de 30 años las mujeres
ocupan puestos electos en lugares como
las alcaldías la gobernación o el
congreso de hecho en el año 2000 una
mujer hizo historia al ser la primera
gobernadora de la isla los estudios
apuntan a que el poder de la mujer en
puerto rico es muy importante
básicamente porque desde los años 80
representan más de la mitad del
electorado sin embargo en estas
elecciones primarias el poder de la
mujer ha quedado empañado básicamente
porque en el partido nuevo progresista
ha ganado pedro pierluisi frente al
actual gobernador a wanda vázquez y lo
mismo ha pasado en el partido popular
democrático ha ganado pedro delgado
frente a la actual alcaldesa de san juan
de puerto rico carmen yulín cruz
[Música]
honduras es uno de los países en aprobar
la ley de paridad de géneros en
candidaturas a cargo de elección popular
esto se dio en el 2012 con
reglamentación en el 2017 sin embargo a
pesar de esta ley que es mayoría en la
población y además domina el padrón
electoral la representación de la mujer
hondureña en cargos a elección popular
es mínima en relación a los hombres
desde la década de los 80 hasta la
actualidad apenas 169 mujeres han sido
electas en el congreso nacional frente a
mil 71 hombres actualmente el congreso
nacional está representado solo por el
21 por ciento de la mujer esto se debe a
que no se aplica de manera correcta esta
ley de paridad de género ya que se da
únicamente de las elecciones internas y
no en las elecciones generales por otro
lado los partidos políticos tampoco
respetan la alternabilidad en la
papeleta electoral y otro factor que
tienen contra la mujer es el
socioeconómico ya que una vez que se
postula a carlos no tiene acceso a
recursos para financiar sus campañas
actualmente el país se prepara
aplicar un nuevo reglamento electoral
donde se espera haya una mayor
participación de las mujeres y además se
respeten los convenios internacionales
que el país ha suscrito en esta misma
línea
[Música]